i think that there are a lot of dark
psychological trends in our society
people are spending all of their time
in front of computers people are they're
not reading
they're detached from certain aspects of
reality
they're disconnected from each other and
i think that they're disconnected from
the drugs that they use they're
disconnected from the food that they eat
they're disconnected from almost every
aspect of their lives
and i think that drugs could have
far-reaching positive effects
if you meet someone at a party for the
first time and they ask
what do you do what's your answer
it depends on what i'm doing at the time
because i do
a number of different things if i'm
directing a tv show
then i'll say i direct a tv show if
i'm writing i'll say
i'm writing an article or i'm doing
research on this story for
a magazine piece or something like that
and if i'm
primarily doing chemistry i'll say i'm
doing chemistry right now i'm doing some
chemistry
so that's just depends on what i'm doing
because i do different
i've tried to balance these three
components of my life and
as best i can not only balance them but
allow them to
feed off of each other and integrate
them into each other
in an interesting way so i think that's
actually been very helpful what ties
those three things together
i think curiosity and a desire
to investigate the natural world
to understand the world that's certainly
a huge goal of chemistry
is to understand the natural world it's
been the focus of almost every
article i've ever written whether it's
about crime or
chemistry or psychoactive drugs to try
to understand
things phenomena how they happen what
happened in the past what's happening
now
and filmmaking is the same thing as well
to try to document things to
characterize them to understand
things that are mysterious i think i've
heard you say before that a lot of
chemistry is in
not superbly accessible formats a lot of
it's in quite sort of
difficult to understand written words
and that was one of the reasons why you
enjoy doing the film making as much as
well to make it a bit more accessible
oh yeah absolutely i mean it it's
kind of amazing to me given how many
people have cameras
and the existence of youtube and the
existence of this international
chemistry community
how many basic chemistry things seem to
have never been filmed before
like i was talking with a uh a chemist
acquaintance in
australia a couple nights ago who's
doing this really cool project of trying
to synthesize this
substance called cubane uh have you ever
heard of this before
no what is it for chemists this is like
one of the coolest things
ever created it's a cube made of carbon
so it's it's uh eight carbon atoms
that are connected in a cube and it's
very very hard to do that because carbon
doesn't want to have 90 degree angles
it's a very strained
uh bond for a carbon atom
and this guy is doing it in his garage
which i just think is so cool
and uh but this is like a very famous
chemical it's in
uh most textbooks and i was thinking
i've never seen a photograph of cuban
i don't know if cubane has ever been
photographed before i don't know
if you know like there's a lot of
industrially important
academically important reactions that
basically
are visually unknown to people they have
no idea what they actually look like
and so that was another big part of it
is
is like one of the you know one of the i
think the most amazing things that i
have learned from years of doing lab
work is that chemistry is beautiful
and and having the
ability to bring that beauty to people
to show them
you know well you might see
methamphetamine synthesis as this
exclusively negative thing or you're
only thinking about it in terms of its
potentially
destructive effect on society but what
about
the the beauty of a solvated electron
i mean it's pretty remarkable some
people go to bed thinking about that at
night
i i do all the time um something that
i thought of while i was watching the
most recent season of your show and your
love for chemistry sort of comes across
really strongly in it
is there isn't i don't think there is
the same
societal cultural fervor and interest in
chemistry
as there is perhaps in physics and
biology at the moment i'm not sure
whether you get the sense of this but
when we think about
all of the the large hadron collider and
we're searching for extraterrestrials
and we're messaging extraterrestrials
and there's new particles being formed
and stuff like that
and then crispr gene editing the side of
i don't know whether that's
technically chemistry or biology or
somewhere in between the two but still
like i just feel like
things like this perhaps don't get the
level of
public exposure that their rival
sciences might do
i agree completely it's absolutely true
and i find it
a little bizarre that
physics and astrophysics of all things
dominate pop science discourse this
discipline that is more disconnected
from our everyday life than almost
anything else and i'm sure there's some
astrophysicists listening to this saying
like what the [ __ ] did he just say
but but that is that is my feeling
it is you know like black holes are
obviously totally fascinating and i am
not
uh going to suggest for a moment that
people shouldn't be interested in black
holes or neutron stars or anything like
that it's totally totally fascinating
i'm fascinated by it
but at the same time it's almost
like science fiction it's almost like
fantasy it has no
connection to our lives whatsoever as
remarkable as it is
whereas chemistry is so
insanely important to our everyday
existence
and is happening immediately around us
inside us in front of us it's
controlling every aspect of our reality
all the time and it's considered boring
so
that is uh is something that i i do find
remarkable and you know and it's not
only remarkable i think it's it's
i've asked myself why how could this
have happened
how how has big astrophysics destroyed
the small interest in chemistry that
should be should be present in every
person
and you know i think there's a lot of
reasons for it but i do think this kind
of like
safety culture fear of the power of
chemistry
fear of psychoactive drugs fear of
explosives fear of poisons
fear of uh toxic wastes all these
different things
have just uh created a culture where
we've kind of
brushed chemistry to the side and
decided that it's
boring dangerous the word chemical is a
bad
thing for many people they you know
chemophobia is what chemists call it
where someone will say oh this food
doesn't contain chemicals and people say
that's a good thing of course
all food is made of chemicals chemicals
are matter better it's just like
you know it's it's all just kind of
shows how disconnected we are
and how you know it's you know you can't
go to a pharmacy in the united states
and get a ph
indicator anymore like we're totally
disconnected from
i would say even the most basic aspects
of chemistry
and um it's really sad because i think
it's a science that
is one of the most ancient scientific
disciplines may be the most
ancient and it especially if you include
metallurgy as a form of chemistry which
it is um
and something that humans have been
connected to for such a long time
so important to who we are how we are
here right now
and and yet it's considered
boring that's why you're here man
how much does a intrigue or an interest
in consciousness
and the phenomenological experience of
our day-to-day experience guide what you
do
i would say it's a huge a huge
motivator i wouldn't say that i'm
especially
optimistic about consciousness being
understood
in the next few years i mean what i
really think is
the case is that um you know there's a
lot of
concepts that aren't really scientific
concepts but they're useful it's like
i think about consciousness the way
historically people would look for life
you know like if you ask a like we're
aware
life exists life is a thing that exists
and if you ask a
biologist can you show me where life is
in a cell
they can't point to life in a cell
because life isn't a single thing
and it can't be discovered
scientifically or
understood scientifically because it's
not really a
scientific concept exactly
it's a sort of collection of phenomena
that we are using to describe something
uh that isn't one thing and i think
consciousness is like life in that
sense that it doesn't actually exist the
way that we
there's you know we're not going to
realize oh the consciousness is
it's the it is the classroom that is
what consciousness it's this region of
the brain and it's
and it's a quantum mechanical
interaction in the classroom and that
produces consciousness no its
consciousness is going to be many many
things in the way that life is many
things and you can reduce what life is
and say okay it's homeostasis it's
reproduction
it's metabolic regulation it's a certain
type of organization
and and we can agree that that those are
uh useful
defining characteristics of life which
of course biologists still to this day
argue about constantly what constitutes
life
um and i i don't think consciousness is
gonna be any simpler
so uh so i am motivated
to understand consciousness but i'm also
doing that with the
uh understanding that i don't think
consciousness will be
understood in a single way because i
don't think it is a thing i think it is
a label that we use to
describe the complex experience of being
or the perceived experience of being
yeah these emergent properties are very
difficult to try and
try and wrangle together when you think
about the synergy of different cells
when does
a particular number of cells become skin
when does it become an
arm when does it become a body when does
it become a human and
i wonder yeah man i mean
we've had a few philosophers on philip
goth talking about the philosophical
schools of consciousness dualism and
uh his his particular
belief as well given that you
seem to have quite a rational scientific
approach to things
it's interesting that you don't think
that we're going to find out what
consciousness is
i would have thought that you would have
maybe expected it to be able to be
explained by science oh i think that
it will be explained by science in the
way that life has been
explained by science but in being
explained by science it will be
explained away
it will not exist anymore
because i don't think it is real i don't
think consciousness exists
in the way that um dna exists
i don't think it's a single thing that
can be understood
and characterized i think it's a a
collection
of different computational experiential
perceptual phenomena
that in concert create
a perceived experience that we call
consciousness but it's not
a thing and so we will understand
how emotion and memory are
regulating aspects of perception and
motivation
and all these things but it's very i
mean it's very complicated
i would think i imagine maybe i'm wrong
maybe it turns out that someone is gonna
find out that it's a really simple thing
and uh and it is one thing and
everything that i'm saying is wrong
but uh my intuitive sense is that there
will never be a
paper published in nature that's you
know consciousness explained here's what
it is it's this one
quantum mechanical interaction and a
microtubule in the classroom and that's
it
i get you what is the place that
psychedelics and other mind-altering
drugs have in life
why should anyone take them
i don't know that anyone should take
them
why would anyone want to take them
perhaps yeah
uh why would anyone want to take them
because
they have the potential to dramatically
enrich your life
in the same way that music and art and
love and a lot of other technically
unnecessary things have the potential to
enrich your life so if someone is saying
you know you don't have to do that you
can do it another way
sure you don't have to listen to music
either you don't have to do a lot of
things
but i don't really see a good reason not
to
um assuming that you know you're doing
it responsibly and
you are you know i suppose
stable enough to benefit experience
somewhere
a lot of the people on the most recent
season of hamilton's pharmacopoeia we're
talking about
psychedelics being sacred you had this
debate around the
uh toad venom and you were saying look
we can save these toads
if we synthesize it in a lab as opposed
to
chasing them down and they talk about
them being sacred
and gifts from the gods and the universe
and stuff like that
how do you feel around this sort of
rhetoric to do with psychedelics
um i feel different ways about it it
kind of depends on what culture
i'm i'm interacting with
um i would say i feel it's like
everything you know if somebody
says something is sacred and there's no
cost to that perspective
then sure that's fine or if it's part of
a
multi-generational tradition and
i have no place interfering with it fine
you know like there's a
belief among many
native american church members
that peyote is
not a drug or a plant that contains a
drug it's a spirit
and to even talk about masculine as an
active principle in the cactus
is a sort of sacrilegious
reductionist perspective that
acknowledge the depth of the spirit of
the peyote
um and so if you say hey come on come on
guys you're
you're gonna drive this plant to
extinction by over harvesting it
and you can synthesize it in a couple of
steps and then you don't have to
interfere with the natural world you
know that's a that's a hard
argument to make that's not an argument
that i'm i would if i made that argument
i'd make it very gently
and i would probably instead start with
um
suggesting that the peyote be cultivated
but they don't even like cultivation and
arguably with good reason because um
a lot of the cultivation techniques
have been focused on growing very large
peyote as opposed to growing
peyote that has a high alkaloid
concentration and so i think some early
attempts to cultivate
peyote for the native american church
produced low potency
cacti that they considered inferior and
so they
this is my impression having reported on
this a few years ago
uh they kind of decided that this
cultivation was it was a bad
route to go down so that's that's you
know a complicated interplay
of tradition indigenous people who have
been
horrendously discriminated against and
marginalized
and something that has had a very
positive effect and then
you want to come in and say hey i know
this is having a really positive effect
on you and your family and your
community but
it's not good for the sustainable uh
life of this cactus so you have to
change your practices you know it's i
can understand why that would be an
objectionable thing
um with the toad i think it's different
because we are dealing with something
that is
not a tradition it is not something
that has been done for generations by
a marginalized group it's a new thing
that started in the 80s
by a white guy in texas
and i actually really find that
important and interesting because
there's a tendency
that many people have to they have to in
order they feel i think some kind of
insecurity about their use of these
things and so they need some
justification they need to say that it's
therapeutic or traditional or spiritual
or something neither they can't just say
i enjoy this
and so you really butt up against that
with modern practices
because there is no tradition there
might be no evidence that it's
therapeutic
and any spirituality associated with it
will be
something that is new and so that
doesn't have the same
value to people and so people basically
invented
a tradition for buffalo various venom
and uh and you know my like i got so
many messages from people saying like
you're just another white colonist
erasing the history
of native americans it's 30 year old
history
yes and uh and it's like but i am
acutely aware of the fact that people
very much want this to be a native
american practice and if anyone produces
any evidence that that is the case i
will
change my mind you know i have no i'm
interested in the truth
so if somebody provides strong evidence
i'll change my perspective on this but
the um
the reason that there is this
misconception is that
there was a there have been a few
discoveries
of large quantities of toad bones one
was in
uh north carolina and the
anthropologist whose name was uh jean
runque i believe um she
and this was also a problem in my
episode like the
article that i show in the episode has
all these mistakes in it but
what i say in the episode is correct but
then people were criticizing me
because there was like a uh it wasn't
like synchronized but
if you whatever i say in the episode is
correct for the record and
uh and so she found all these toad
bones and knew that there were some
toads that produced psychoactive
tryptamines and wrote this
paper that suggested that that was the
case and it's kind of sensational people
like
any story about ancient use of
psychedelics myself included
and uh and so it got written up a little
bit in the popular press in omni
magazine which is a big magazine at that
time
and um and this is really interesting
the way it happened and so this guy ken
nelson
saw this in omni magazine and then
went to try to recreate
what he had read about but what's really
interesting is
that was misreported in omni magazine so
a
mistaken report a mistaken
interpretation of this native american
practice
caused a real discovery to occur
the all current evidence
uh there's an anthropologist named
matthew compton who looked into this
uh points toward the toads having been
used as a food source not as a drug and
there's a
lot of reasons for that there's a lot of
evidence one one is that buffalo various
which is the only species that produces
five meodmt
is not present in the carolinas
and uh and so there's that
there is no plausible psychedelic toad
also um there are
documented that there's a book i
actually have it of
like traditional cherokee
practices in food preparation and has
infection on the preparation of toads
for consumption and they talk about how
to detoxify it so it's the opposite of
using it as a drug they're trying to
remove
any potentially toxic principles so that
it can be consumed um
so yeah you it's and toads are a decent
source of food so like it doesn't really
make
sense that there would be all these like
uh toad skeletons
if it were used as a drug but it would
make a lot of sense
given that there weren't any psychedelic
toads in that region that they were
using them as a food okay
so this misconception caused him to get
interested in the possibility and then
he independently actually
discovered that you could milk the venom
of this toad
and smoke it based on some research by
an italian
uh biologist named vitorio or spamer
complicated story i don't blame people
for being confused by it it's very
confusing
um but that's that's what happened so
all these people are saying how dare you
like you said that
he discovered it from a cherokee uh a
midden pile and then you're saying that
a white person discovered it
but the complicated thing is it was a
misunderstanding of what that cherokee
midden pile was
okay i hope that made sense i don't know
if that did that make sense
man yeah i mean yeah it's not bad as
misrepresentations go that you get to
open up an entire new world
of psychedelic experience what's your
what's your opinion on the sacredness
coming along for the ride
do you think there's anything more
happening during the experience of
taking a psychedelic than just
the interaction of the chemicals with
your brain
are we accessing a higher power is there
someone talking to us is it energy in
the universe
well what i find funny is people are
constantly
invoking the supernatural in
places where just simple psychology is
sufficient
you don't need to uh you don't need to
go into the spirit realm
to understand that there are non
or non exclusively externally chemical
determinants of experience
so this and this goes back to the 60s
you know timothy leary did experiments
at millbrook
where he would put lsd in milk
that was dyed red and then he'd put lsd
in milk that was dyed green
and then he'd put lsd and milk that was
dyed black and he would say
this lsd does this and this lsd does
that and of course
people would have different experiences
based on the different colored lsds
and the different types of experiences
that he'd primed them for
so this is like basic psychology and of
course leary was a psychologist
so it uh it really makes sense that if
you
tell someone hey this was you know
harvested from the sacred venom of a
sacred toad
it's a medicine that they they're
you know they estivate in a subterranean
den
for nine months just like human
gestation and they
and they uh create this this chemical
that
that causes a rebirth and this is their
gift to us and
to increase our ecological awareness or
whatever you can make a beautiful story
and and for the record i have smoked the
venom and had an absolutely amazing
experience with it so
i get it i get why i think it's cool
i'm i'm not one of these people that you
know like i understand why people like
it
i think it's amazing i totally get it
but it's not sustainable and
with the popularity increasing at the
rate that it currently is
there needs to be a different way of
doing it um you know
it hasn't been studied as well as i
would like it to and one of the
things that i'm doing with this episode
is i republished the book that ken
nelson wrote
and i'm donating all the profits to
charity and it's been this like
unexpected insanely successful
fundraising effort like at as of today i
think it's raised 130
000 for the michael j fox foundation for
parkinson's research
but also there's separate money going to
uh the tucson herpetological society
and you know i really want to get some
carefully
documented data on how the populations
are impacted because
most of what i know is anecdotal it's
you know i i spoke with
a number of the people that uh milk
buffalo various for a living and those
people if anyone have incentive to
downplay the severity of any ecological
disruption because their livelihood
depends on it and even those people were
saying
this is not sustainable like this is not
a good uh
this is not a good practice so
so it's not that i'm i do believe
that people can have different
experiences based on
different substances but i think that
the
determining factor is psychological not
chemical unless you have a reason to
believe
that it is and of course i am aware also
that psychology is you know
biochemically determined but but i'm
talking about the chemistry of the drug
itself
like that if you i think that
with the appropriate tradition and the
appropriate
packaging you can get you can extract
that from any
substance in the same way that you could
make the best lsd in the world
feel bad to people if you you know
served it to them in like a pot in like
a brown
tar and said that had been scraped from
underneath the toilet
and uh and that it was like cursed by
a serial killer or or something like
that like these
these uh these things impact the
experience
um completely that's the fascinating
thing about set in settings i i don't
need
to make sure that i'm in a good place
for ibuprofen to do its job properly
or like aspirin to do its job properly
but the environment that you're in and
the mindset that you have going into the
experience does
inherently change the experience of the
substance that you're taking when it
comes to mind-altering stuff
yeah oh absolutely absolutely and and
that's
that is one useful thing to come out of
this
um kind of unusual new tradition there
are these two
medical doctors in mexico who have
become toad venom evangelist and they're
very controversial in the toad venom
community
um i was also getting a lot of criticism
from people that were saying why didn't
you
talk about how bad these guys are well
you know i like i can't fight everyone's
fights with these people for them but
it's they have
there's a lot of infighting a lot of
anger in the toad venom community and i
think
part of it has to do with the power of
this substance you know
i think that um from what i can tell
some of the
they call themselves facilitators the
people that that give
5meo dmt containing toad venom to people
almost become addicted to the power of
the transformation
that they are promoting with the
administration of the substance
you know you can imagine being a
psychologist or something
and you know doing talk therapy with
people for years
and never you might never see a change
you might
never see even the smallest change in
someone's behavior
and you can imagine the feeling of
futility
that that would promote in someone who's
dedicated their lives to healing
and then you have a substance that
will cause absolutely
extraordinary change spiritual
experience transformation
life-changing transformation in people
immediately and how
encouraging that could be to someone to
think
you know how could you do anything but
that
what else you know what else would be
worth your time as a healer but to
administer the substance so i see where
they get a little um lost in it
themselves
and and to be honest there's an element
of that with me as well where i
you know when i had this experience when
i came out of it i
one of the first thoughts i had was you
know given the skills that i have
how can i help other people have this
experience and for me
that was chemistry that was you know i
if i can
show people that this is a simple
molecule that can
easily be produced by someone with the
undergrad chemistry knowledge um and uh
and and made available to anyone that
needs it then that will
have a positive effect on the world why
would you want other people to
experience what you did
what was the benefit that you saw from
it
um you know i i would say that it's many
of the benefits that people typically
associate with a near-death experience
where you feel extreme gratitude for
life
you feel an appreciation
for the beauty of the world that you can
very easily
take for granted you know i was totally
tenderized i was hyper
sensitive in the wake of this experience
i uh
hypersensitized in every way i would you
know be moved to tears by
the beauty of a cute dog walking down
the street
um just like totally totally
amazed by plants and all life
and i think that that without even
medicalizing it now like
obviously that has a lot of potential
for treatment of depression and various
diseases addiction and so on and so
forth but even for a healthy person
that's pretty nice that's a useful
little
change of pace to remind you that life
is a gift and that it's beautiful and
that it should be appreciated because
it's
really really unbelievably strange and
interesting and
cool why do you think it is
that people have these religious
experiences why do you think the
phenomenological and not just with the
toad venom but with
many things many psychedelics induce
this sort of
sacred religious state i'm communicating
with higher powers
one of the thought experiments i've been
playing around with for
ages is what would happen to someone did
you ever see the film mother
it was made by netflix oh you don't have
a tv
i don't know the darren aronofsky movie
maybe was it about the girl that was
raised by a robot
uh oh i watched half of it on an
airplane
okay so you know the premise right i
believe so
you you have this human that is raised
with
essentially no culture they're given
words because they have language
but they're not given any cultural
influence it's just them essentially in
a petri dish
the petri dish just happens to be a big
building that they live in
have you ever considered what would
happen to someone who hadn't been
imprinted by culture
if they were to take a psychedelic
well yeah i mean i consider it all the
time uh i because i'm very interested in
the way animals
respond to psychedelics and uh and what
a psychedelic experience is
for a rodent or if there even is a
psychedelic experience for a rodent
and um it's hard enough to
conceptualize experience for another
human being let alone an animal or
someone that
has no cultural imprinting or anything
like that so it's sort of
hard to say but what do you think what
is uh what do you think would happen
well i mean i think based on my very
mild
introduction to psychedelics stuff like
the geometric patterns that you seem to
see
tends they would be fairly ubiquitous
they don't necessarily require the
cultural imprinting for instance if you
were to take something like psilocybin
and you get
that sort of hexagonal psychedelic
effect in front of you like a
kaleidoscope that i don't think that
that
requires culture um
it would be so interesting man like
would you
if you don't know what a dragon is can a
dragon chase you down if you don't know
what a snake is can you be scared of a
snake
like is it blob i'm trying to remove the
programming
from this particular human in the test
tube that we're talking about
and see what's left when you introduce
the psychedelic to them
yeah well i mean one one thing that i
would imagine is
religious experience i think that that
um
this psychedelic experience probably
is a religious experience i imagine as
someone who is you know
atheist agnostic it's certainly the
closest
i ever get to what i imagine religious
transcendence
is like and so i think that yeah
it could promote some some version
of that i mean the other thing to keep
in mind is that
like and one reason that drug education
is so important
is the way we think about drugs impacts
the experience as i was saying
previously
so little things like you know just even
the way people talk about drugs or that
people are burnt out they're acid burned
they're
frying on acid all this you know there's
people that think
that drug the drug experience is like a
form of brain damage
and you know outside of it being a
misconception
it also makes me wonder what does that
person feel like when they take lsd if
they think that it's bad
if if they think that this is they're
frying on
acid and that it's like that it's
damaging to them in some way how could
you possibly
have a good experience that way i mean
there's also quite a lot of people
that seem to think that the mushroom
experience is a form of food poisoning
you hear that all have you heard that at
least in the u.s people people will
say like hey my my friend told me that
when you trip on mushrooms it's just
food poisoning
and uh and i think like wow there are
people that have
mushroom experiences who think that what
is happening is
food poisoning um
i've heard you talk about um some of the
residual guilt that you get when you
sometimes used to smoke weed
because it's kind of associated with
this i'm being a bit of a waste man
i should be working i should be studying
i should be being productive
and that's almost exclusively because of
how you've been socialized what do other
people say
about people who take that drug that's
true it's well it's true
it's true and it's not true it's it's
very it's very
complicated i think with cannabis that's
one of the more complicated ones
because um i think that
one of the advantages and disadvantages
of cannabis is that it allows you
at least allows me it does different
things to everyone it allows me
to take things less seriously a lot less
seriously
um and that's great sometimes
and not great uh not great as a
daily alteration of consciousness so
you know it's very easy for me to just
you know i'm receiving like a hundred
emails a day from disgruntled weirdos
and i think uh you know like oh what is
wrong with these people how could they
possibly watch what i made and think and
extract
that of all possible interpretations
what is going on
but then if i'm stoned i think ah all
right well
i don't know i guess i guess people
think
strange things and that's just uh the
way it's gonna be for that guy
but but um and so that's that can be
extremely extremely beneficial
uh in if you're living a frustrating
life or you're just
totally occupied with your professional
responsibilities or your studies or
whatever
but too much of it at least for me and
it has a bit of a dissociative type of
fact where i
i'm not as engaged with the world which
again
can be beneficial it really just depends
on the context
and i agree with you that you could you
could make a valid argument
that this is all conditioning and
especially conditioning from a
capitalist society that values
productivity over everything else
over joy over relaxation
over uh camaraderie with friends over
almost anything
so yes like i think that
there are many extremely stoned people
who are living a beautiful
existence that is disconnected from
our american european
value system that where if you're not
just constantly generating things
you're of no value um and and of course
there are also people
that get sown all the time and are
immensely productive and are able to
you know do huge amounts of work and i
have a lot of respect for those
people i'm not one of them uh so
no me neither do you think any drugs
should be illegal
what's your stance on the legalization
of drugs
no i do not think any drugs should be
illegal
um i think that
and i'm aware that my perspective on
this can sound a little bit
doctrinaire and i try to remember
that that there are people who are just
so irresponsible that maybe certain
types of regulations are
required for public safety you know um
certainly i think that it's really good
that radioactive
materials are regulated i i do i mean i
think it's
it's we we there is a history spanning
uh like over a hundred years of people
just doing irresponsible things with
radioactive materials
and the government is very careful about
regulating
how radioactive materials are
distributed and i appreciate that i
think that's really
useful because you know if someone is
selling you
some flour extract as a treatment for
covid or whatever
fine you know let maybe not find
but it's not it's not going to
kill the person i hope most likely i
mean i suppose there is exceptions for
everything
but you know radioactive materials
routinely make their way
into quack medicine and uh and that's
you know that's really tragic for the
people that get caught up in that sort
of thing same thing with these
um these you know like nitrile uh
like what is that compound that's used
as a quack cancer treatment like late
lat trial or whatever it's like a
base science program so
like i think that some um
some some things
when they're sold as medicines and are
extremely dangerous
should be regulated but i think that if
things
aren't being sold as medicines just as
chemicals they should be available
pretty much everything within reason but
not radioactive things
probably probably not radioactive so if
it's not a radioactive psychedelic it's
fine
and there are radioactive i've actually
uh like
um tim ferriss was really nice and he
like donated some money to
uh to the lab that i work at and we used
it to synthesize a radioactive
psychedelic that we use for experiments
so did you take it um
oh absolutely not no no it's it's really
[ __ ] up
yeah wow
but um but
yeah it's you know drug policy is really
complicated and i wish i had a simple
answer to what people should do because
um because i
but but i think that with liberalization
with increased education with
decriminalization people will
begin to work out how to use these
things and maybe bad things will happen
but that's the price of freedom and i
think that as a culture
we will mature and evolve to navigate
that freedom
i mean there's just a lot of dangerous
things that happen all the time
roads are dangerous cars are insanely
dangerous but we have seat belts and
airbags
and we have regulations where uh you
there are legal penalties for driving
irresponsibly and i think
that it's not much of a stretch to
assume that we could have a similar
attitude toward
chemicals that are potentially dangerous
i mean we've seen a big cultural shift
with the attitude towards cannabis right
over the last sort of 30 years or so do
you think that uh
model that we're going to see with other
drugs moving forward it would appear
that
psilocybin's kind of at the beginning of
that threshold a little bit of
legalization a little bit of therapeutic
use it's starting to get hold of the
culture in a way that makes it seem less
demonized
is this just going to continue to expand
out and cover the entire
mind-altering drug market i think it
will
yeah because these are good things these
are things that will
have a good effect on many people's
lives
and that could really help a lot of
people like i genuinely believe that
some of these things
you know i try to be very balanced and
sober
in my thinking about the subject and not
get into you know say
cannabis cures all diseases or uh
psilocybin is going to
you know cure all of society's ills or
whatever but
you know i think that
there are a lot of dark psychological
trends in our society people are
spending all of their time
in front of computers people are very
they're not reading they're detached
from
certain aspects of reality they're
disconnected from each other
and i think that um they're disconnected
from the drugs that they use they're
disconnected from the food that they eat
they're disconnected from almost every
aspect of their lives
and i think that drugs could have
like far-reaching positive effects like
i was even thinking
like yesterday like what if there were
cannabis community gardens
and people could just garden cannabis
like how much fun that would be for as
for a community and you could go and
people would would just
hang out and it would be fun for young
people and
old people and people could gather and
play music or things like that you know
these things bring people together we're
so used to talking about how drugs tear
apart families that we never or tear
apart relationships or
people's careers or whatever that we
forget but they're also
extremely social i mean that's the main
thing that people
use them for most of the time is to be
with other people to bond with people to
socialize
and uh and i think that you know
a lot of people would get interested in
growing plants
and fungi if they were able to do it
whatever they wanted if they had freedom
um and i think that
like what are the downstream effects
people become more interested in drugs
then they become more interested in
therapy they become more interested in
art they become more interested in
science
they become more interested in helping
their community i think like
i think that the responsibility
associated with
the liberalization of drug laws will
actually
help mature the world like in a
good very beneficial way um because
this idea that they're bad and they're
dangerous and anyone who
uses them deserves what they get like
it's amazing how little empathy people
have um and and these are all just
unfortunate vestiges of the war on drugs
like i've heard people say things like
uh
you know like p like junkies should get
one shot of narcan and then after that
it's up to them let them die
you know things like what are you
talking about why do you why would you
want to regulate
how often someone gets a life-saving
intervention why do you hate these
people
where is your like what did they ever
what did someone who's
dependent on opioids ever do to you and
why
don't you just see it as a medical
problem that should be treated with
empathy and care and science
like anything else i mean meanwhile that
person's having
half a bottle of wine per night and a
few cans on a weekend
right right i mean it's it's our whole
our concept of what
constitutes addiction is so bizarre and
distorted i
i can't tell you how many people i've
met who are sober
like pub like on instagram like
five months sober yeah
who are more addicted to drugs
than like than certainly i have ever
been i mean i
because but they will say oh yeah i'm a
dependent on opioids but they're
prescribed by a physician for pain so
it's not
and it's like okay well then you have a
very distress nothing against people
that do that
but it's you know it's like if you need
to
do that while simultaneously declaring
that you are
sober and that drug abuse is a problem
then you have a very confused attitude
toward
your drug use i think there's
there's so much pleasure that we can all
take from highlighting hypocrisy
and my other favorite one that's
happened over the last couple of years
has been people adopting the veganism
movement
but still sniffing cocaine i run
nightclubs
i run a lot of nightclubs and um i
obviously see quite a lot of party drugs
and people who are outwardly very
concerned about the suffering of animals
but not so outwardly concerned about the
suffering of people in medellin
or other like humans that have been
trafficked or caught or
shot or killed or tortured or in any
other way mistreated
so that they can get a buzz on on a
friday or a saturday night
well that's a complicated one i i am
kind of on the fence about the moral
implications of using cocaine because
because i've heard that argument
and you know those those are not again
maybe this is my
my like idealistic attitude not
reflecting
the practical aspects of reality but
um you know those are not issues with
cocaine those are issues with
prohibition
and so it's like is it unethical to use
cocaine uh maybe
it's not the chain the cocaine's not the
issue it's the externality of the
process that we have to go through to
get it at the moment right
yeah and the fact that it's all that is
a product of it being illegal not a
product of
people using cocaine or cocaine and as a
plant alkaloid that's exclusively
what happens in a black market economy
and so i don't know that i think that
using cocaine is unethical
as much as i would maybe hope that
anyone that really enjoys cocaine
also cares about drug policy a little
bit and maybe they are
you know thinking about what needs to be
done to reform drug policy in
the regions where coca is grown to uh
to minimize the negative impact that it
can have on those communities which is
you know it's not easy fair trade
cocaine
you're joking but people actually i've
heard people talk about that of like
you know yeah people do things like that
actually
and i've heard people talk about it um
and uh and yeah so
but again this is you know this is like
all this stuff is just
a product of the illegality of
these substances it doesn't need to be
that way at all it could be
an uplifting plant that
provides a source of income for many
people which it is i mean it's you know
it's also there's a
huge uh market for coca that is not
illegal
coca-cola of course still uses coca
in its formulation and you have
although it's decoconized and you have
um
you know you have an enormous coca tea
industry
all sorts of coca candies cocoa products
that are used
in south america so um
it's you know it is i think a very
positive
plant and the only negative
aspects of it come from its illegality
do you ever wish that you could have
tried some of the original coca-cola
yeah i think that would have been i
think yeah i mean i actually think like
i i'm not a big
i i ha you couldn't pay me to
to sniff the sort of cocaine that uh
that exists seriously i mean i wouldn't
and i don't uh and but
as a teenager i used it a few times and
um and i've analyzed a decent bit of
cocaine and of course
it's all horrendously impure and um
and but when it's taken orally
in a tea it's very nice it's really very
very sick and that's already like i
think that's actually the best way to do
it
like this is another kind of aspect of
the way black markets
shape drug usage trends is you have
um like a risk premium that's paid so
you have to
you know you're you're transporting the
substance you have to transport it in
the
most potent most concentrated form
possible because it's
sometimes you know coming on drones in
submarines
smuggled in airplanes smuggled in
people's bodies
you know this is this is incredibly
difficult and dangerous so you want the
absolute most potent form of the
substance that you're bringing into the
country
well that's the best for black market
smuggling of an illegal commodity but is
that the best way to use
cocaine almost certainly not it's
probably
the absolute worst way to use cocaine
the best way to use cocaine
is coca leaves in a warm tea in the
morning
and as you you know read the news or
whatever that's the best way to use
cocaine
that is nice it feels very similar to
caffeine
it does not seem to produce any negative
physiological effects for users
it does seem to produce positive effects
for many people
and that is the way that people use it
traditionally
in everywhere that there is a tradition
where it's not illegal
it's only it's really like all of these
horrible things that we associate with
cocaine are really horrible things
associated with cocaine's illegality
that's such an interesting point i had a
story to tell you actually so i have a
friend who's a who's a dj and
he travels a lot and he does tours and
stuff like that he's telling me this
story
about when he was in south america and
obviously
cocaine has quite a luxurious
brand attached to it it's kind of seen
as the lamborghini so to speak of like
party drugs you know it's expensive
it's um conspicuous consumption it would
be called by the sociologists
and um he was down in argentina or
mexico or wherever it was and uh he was
asking the promoter
someone in his entourage asset promoter
if they could get a hold of some cocaine
and the promoter looked at them like
they'd asked for
i don't know like heroin in the uk or
something like that and he's like
really you want that and what it turned
out was that because
it's so cheap to get a hold of cocaine
wherever
the guys were that was seen as a really
scummy drug
the branding for cocaine down there was
awful
whereas 2cb which if you were to take
that in the uk would be like what you
why are you taking 2cb on a night out
but because 2cb over there is
100 pounds a hit or 50 pounds a hit or
something like that
that is the drug which is put on a
pedestal that's the one that's all about
status
and because cocaine's so cheap that's
the one that's seen
as a a really sort of scummy awful drug
that people shouldn't take
i thought that was really hilarious to
see how cultural interpretations of
drugs completely change how they're
positioned
that's absolutely true i actually wanted
to dedicate an entire episode to that in
the third season and i was going to do
two cb labs in south america but i
wasn't able to
find a chemist who was making it i
really tried i we had a team scouting
really trying to if anyone listening to
this
is associated with the synthesis of 2cb
in south america please do contact me
i'd love to
have a conversation about it because i
think it's totally fascinating and i
completely agree with what you said
that a lot of the way we perceive these
drugs is
a product of the way they're marketed
their cost
their social connotations um
there was a drug in the uk called
mephadrone are you
familiar with that yeah that when mcat
or meow m
yeah yeah yeah which had a very as i
understand it as a
american a very very bad reputation in
the uk
it was like really disgusting of course
because it doesn't smell very nice it
smelled really strong
and it was basically the poor person's
version of taking cocaine
but dude there was a period i [ __ ] you
not there was a period in uk nightlife
where people would rack that up on a bar
on a bar because it wasn't a controlled
substance yet and if the door staff
would come over and quite rightly say
excuse me what the [ __ ] are you doing
they'll just be like mate
not illegal and obviously they get
thrown out for being a dick
but the police could come the police
could come up
and there's nothing there was nothing to
be done it didn't last very long there
wasn't a big
period of time i remember man once i got
a broadcast message on whatsapp
and it must have been a couple of weeks
before this stuff became illegal
and someone was trying to sell kilos of
it they're like oh we're trying to shift
couple of does anyone want a couple of
kilos of mcat
before the new legislation comes in what
no no who wants that but yeah very much
so that was exactly the same
like i mean the the effect of it it's
very speedy have you ever tried it
oh yeah have you yeah i've tried i think
it's one of the greatest drugs ever
discovered i
am a huge fan of it really yes wow
yes yeah yeah it's very i think that
it's a perfect
rushy and i think it's a perfect example
of
it was considered disgusting garbage it
was the
grimiest stuff out there and so
no one cared they just it was junk no
one cared about it no one appreciated it
but i guarantee if someone had
carefully presented you with mephadrone
and said you know there's a brilliant
biochemist who spent his entire
life studying the serotonin transporter
and the dopamine transporter and the
balance of
dopamine reuptake inhibition to
serotonin release is
optimized for maximum euphoria with no
neurotoxic effect
then you would have had a totally
different experience and uh
and i think that yeah that it was it was
like not appreciated
at all as a substance when in fact i
think that it was um
in terms of like a what people are
looking for in a recreational drug i
think that it
represented almost like the perfect
recreational drug um
have you considered going into branding
you could re-write you could rebrand
some of these drugs and give them a new
name
give them a new honestly i i genuinely
think the price was a big part of it
the fact it was so cheap and price is
seen as an indicator of quality
if it had been 50 pounds of gram as
opposed to there was a period where you
could get it for between
five and ten pounds a gram are you
talking like one twentieth to one tenth
of what it should be for cocaine yeah
yeah it's it's um it's really really
interesting and the other thing that you
mentioned that i think is also really
interesting
is that when a drug is made illegal
it causes people to panic
by enormous quantities of it so this
guy that's selling you a kilo or trying
to sell you a kilo
that was not uncommon that was happening
to people all over the uk
and similar things have happened in the
united states so
the government announces their plan to
make kratom illegal what is the first
thing i do i don't even like kratom at
all i never use them
and uh and and the first thing i do is
buy a kilo of it
because i think uh well you know maybe
maybe they'll just regulate it in like
on a state level and it's better to and
maybe it'll be hard to get and i might
want to use it in scientific research
and who knows
and so suddenly i have like a massive
quantity of this substance i don't even
like or want to use it's just like
gathering
dust in my closet and uh and
and that would have never happened if
the dea hadn't
announced their intention to prevent
people from accessing it
so this panic buying is a reality with
psychoactive drugs i mean
it is you could hardly think of a worse
way
to regulate use of psychoactive drugs in
the way that the government currently
does it it is
it is it would be funny if it weren't
so horrendously tragic they have the
streisand effect as well with this right
it's like
don't bother looking about this and then
everybody wants to know what the hot new
[ __ ] is oh wow oh god
like schedule one like that that must be
some strong [ __ ]
gotta get me gotta get me some of that
yeah
yeah and and because of the totally
warranted
distrust of the media um you know
like no journalist every journalist is
writing these sensational stories about
illegal drug teen tears there scrotum
off
from meow meow that's that was a real
that's i that's what i remember the
story
verbatim headline from the sun i believe
and uh
and you know oh i mean here's a funny
story the
the reporting was so insane at that time
that they were just publishing anything
and i started to think
like what is what are the barriers
for entry here like can i just contact
one of these journalists and just
say some insane thing and it will end up
in the sun so
i uh like at the beginning of this
conversation i was talking about cubane
so i was thinking like wouldn't it be
hilarious to chemists if i said that
like
four cubanal methcathinone
like this just like absurd molecule that
has never been synthesized
were like a new mefodrone derivative
that
was taking the uh the uk by storm so i
wrote a journalist at the sun
and said like you know i'm a chemist
i've done a lot of work with substituted
cubans
and uh and you know you really need to
be aware of this
for cubenal methcathino and it's a
serious problem and and i hope that you
care enough about
you know your readers at the sun to
raise awareness and they immediately
contacted me
they got my phone number they called me
on the phone and then when they were
doing the interview i was like ah i
can't
i can't go through with this this is too
too much
journalistic integrity man you should
have just done it yeah
i should have done it as like but then i
just starting to think like
you know it's really horrifying we don't
live in a mature enough society for
for pranks like that because it's like
what then then what are they going to
make cubane
illegal as a result of my stupid joke
like you know it's something
something like that is not out of the
question
so um so i just started to think okay
this is
this is too much but they would write
they would report anything
and so people don't trust anything that
they say justifiably
and so the like any potential public
health
interventions that could in an ideal
world come through the media are totally
meaningless because no one trusts
anything that they say
and and if anything serve as as you said
like streisand's
uh a fact like advertisements for these
substances that people
know whether they're good or bad the
media would never
uh represent them accurately so you
might as well give it a shot
are there any drugs that you haven't
taken or any substances that you still
want to
oh i mean you know the chemical space is
virtually infinite and so there are
a near infinite number of drugs that i
have not taken
and um and there are
specific unusual things that i
would hope at some point in my life to
evaluate many of them i'm not in a rush
to try
because they are either potentially
dangerous or potentially
potentially very disruptive to my
functioning
for periods of time so they're not uh
high on the list
and um you know i've i i would say that
i have
experienced many of the things that i
want to
experience in that realm and my interest
now is primarily in
synthesis and uh discovery of new things
that's you know i think that there are
so many
amazing traditions out there and i've
had the
tremendous privilege of being able to
spend time with many
different indigenous groups and learn
about the way that they use psychoactive
plants and fungi and and
now my hope would be to integrate all
the things that i've learned in my
travels
and and try to use it to inform the
discovery of new compounds and try to
think about the best ways that these
compounds can be integrated into our
culture
the interesting thing that i find about
your work is that although you're
obviously
engaged in the substances that you take
and you're very inquisitive about what
does this feel like
you're pretty good at describing the
phenomenological experience of it as
well
but i've never seen you cross the line
into someone who's just
kind of recreationally being very blase
around the drugs it seems like there's
quite a lot of respect for them
obviously you come at this from the side
of a chemist as well i know that you
always talk about
knowing dosages correctly like super
super anal
around when it comes to what's the
dosage exactly what am i taking what's
the level of purity and stuff like that
but um yeah i think it's
from my perspective as someone who's
been around a lot of drugs for a long
time especially in the party scene where
people are taking
they they literally have no idea what it
is like it could be a caffeine pill it
could be an aspirin
it could be a gram of mdma you just
don't know
um and seeing that i'd just call it
respect for drugs
i suppose um i think it's a really good
example to be set
is that something that you consciously
try and do to come across in a
overly responsible way yeah it is
because i mean there's a number of
reasons for it but one is that
having that respect it's not some
abstract
thing you know this directly impacts the
experience and has a very positive
effect so when people will say these
things to me like
what's the craziest thing you've ever
done aren't you afraid that you're gonna
go
like you're never gonna come back it's
like well i'm extremely cautious
so i don't know what to tell you i'm
very
careful and so i would be much people
like i yeah some woman came up to me at
whole foods and was like how are you
still alive
it's like how am i still alive on my
walk home
from work i see people dead drunk on the
street
who are more intoxicated than i've ever
been every day
so like why is it like this is we're so
confused
by anyone that is like open about their
occasional responsible use of substances
that we assume that that person must be
a maniac
and so even when i'm very cautious
people have that attitude the other
thing
is that even at the the times when i was
like the first piece i ever made i was
21
and i was making it it was uh a
trip down the amazon uh
to to find this
frog phila medusa by color that is the
one where you got burned
was yeah i've seen that yeah yeah i was
21 i was a college student i was
deeply unaware of many things and
in particular i was unaware of the way
my actions would be perceived by other
people because
it's not until you make things for
public consumption that you start to
even think about
that because you're you know you're with
your friends you're with people that
know you
people basically get what you're doing
and who you are
and so you don't have to think too much
about ways will be perceived
and one of the things that i did
is i took ritalin with ayahuasca
and i to this day am criticized by
people robotically it's like
like if people are criticizing me
they'll be like that guy you're talking
about the guy who took ritalin with
ayahuasca
quite frankly i wouldn't trust him at
all and they don't understand
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter that
for the record it is not dangerous to
combine ritalin with ayahuasca
i maybe i shouldn't say that publicly
but for the record it is
you know ritalin is metabolized by
hepatic
hydrolases so it's not metabolized by
mao the enzyme
that is inhibited by the beta-carbolines
in the ayahuasca vine
so there is no potentiation of
ritalin by monoamine oxidase inhibitors
okay
that's just the way it is so you can
talk about how it's dangerous
all day but it's simply
i mean i'm not gonna recommend other
people do it but
ritalin is not metabolized by mao so
and uh and and so i you know all these
but i have to deal with it it doesn't
matter that what i did wasn't dangerous
what matters is that people say that
it's dangerous and then they harass me
about it and they write it on forums and
then they robotically repeat it
uncritically and never actually
learn about the metabolism of ritalin
and so like
just that is an example it's like you
have to think about what is what is
going to be the
like decade-long fallout of some little
action you know like and there's part of
me that thinks like well
i guess maybe okay good because i showed
that
i was honest about something but you
know there's a price for that type of
honesty and it can be very obnoxious
i think that the main problem we're
coming up here is this a singular thread
which is
through a lot of things not just your
work but almost everybody else when you
talk about
child youtubers or people who've been on
twitter for a decade
society and civilization just isn't
meant to have all of the things that we
did or said
like encased in stone and able to be
re-accessed perfectly
for the rest of time like that's just
not the way that it's supposed to happen
it's supposed to be the thing happens
and then maybe it was right maybe it was
wrong but after
10 years or so people can't remember it
in any case and half of them have died
and that's how our society grew over
time but now
sadly the things that you did or said
when you were 13 or 17 or
21 they're just enshrined for the rest
of your days and that's going to be
you know potentially that could be the
thing now that's oh you're the you're
the ritalin and ayahuasca guy
and you know you've got to spend the
rest of your life trying to constantly
wipe this slime off you right and and
for
and it's especially annoying because
there is nothing wrong with it it's
like you're also battling against
people's bizarre misinterpretations of
things that's the really the biggest
issue is not actual problems
it's things that people have decided our
problems and their critical thinking
skills aren't good enough
to recognize that whatever it is that
they're angry about isn't actually an
issue
um yeah there's that and then there's
another problem
that i think about a lot which is i
think people have become so disconnected
from the act of creation
many people they're that they confuse
consumption with creation
and they think that the order that they
view things
is the order that those things exist in
reality so
like some you know some like
some cultural critic was writing a
snotty review of my show recently
and he was talking about how you know he
he had a lot of hope for me because he
read this great harper's article that i
wrote
but then he saw this horrible video that
i made
later about crystal coal and again this
is another misconception that people
robotically
repeat because they're not capable of
critically thinking about things but
anyway
but what was really annoying to me is
he's talking about uh he's talking about
a
like he he's confusing the chronology of
my work
because that that's the order that he
looked at things that's not the order
that they happened and i see that all
the time where people
are like so disconnected that they don't
even care
about when things are created or where
they're created or the context i mean a
lot of websites now have to put a notice
on articles that say this article is
five years old because people won't even
look at the date that things are made
because
they don't seem to even care and and
it's not those people's fault entirely
like we
are being disconnected from the act of
creation
like in all sorts of different ways like
on
most streaming uh web services
they cut out the credits entirely now
why would you want to look at the
credits that's just
names of people that made it that's not
important it's like
that is who made it that is the
information that is extremely important
you should
maybe you don't recognize the names but
if you care about it you should look at
them
and maybe you can learn more about if
that episode is particularly beautiful
maybe you should look into who
photographed it who is the director of
photography in that episode what else
have they done maybe that explains it
maybe it wasn't
the like overarching media corporation
that distributed it
maybe it was a human being who should be
appreciated or whatever so
like i don't know that's like a
complicated like
overarching issue i have with
contemporary media literacy
but uh it's it's a rough time and i
agree we did not evolve
to have like these uh
these lasting records and we have not
culturally evolved
to maturely recognize that fact like all
of this uh you know offense archaeology
all this stuff where people
spend enormous amounts of time trying to
dig up evidence that somebody said
something that was bad
15 years ago it's it's that is not
integrating this understanding that you
just described
that like people change that we didn't
evolve to be to have this timeless
record of every single thing that we had
said
and uh and i don't know i don't know
like what the solution to this is other
than
you know like improved cultural literacy
and or improved media literacy
culturally
and uh and kind of like empathy for that
fact and empathy for
people in general i don't know i don't
know what the solution is either man
like nick bostrom has this idea about
pulling different types of technology
out of an urn
and he says that there is a temptation
to pull out a black ball and the black
ball is an existential risk
but i am really really concerned that
social media and ubiquitous
communication that stores everything
that everyone's ever said or done
forever
is a slowly transforming black ball
it might only be gray at the moment but
it's getting darker gray and darker gray
and darker gray all the time and
the reason for that is that it causes us
to increasingly
look at what other people are doing as
opposed to trying to create something
ourselves
perfect example of this is are you
familiar with lindy do you know what
lindy is
the gas company no no um
it's a particular heuristic it's a model
for
how long something has been around if
something has been around for a while
the classics
have been around for a long time so you
read 1984 which has been around for 50
years
it's probably going to be around for
another 50 years it basically is a
heuristic that says the most recent
stuff isn't necessarily the best read
the classics for a reason
but yeah if you think about what most
people have spent
today consuming almost all of the
content
that everyone listening to this show has
consumed today will have been created
within the last 24 hours
and that should [ __ ] terrify almost
everybody do you think that's the
opposite of lindy
that isn't the classics that isn't stuff
that stood stood the test of time
that is just someone's
someone's meandering thoughts whilst
they're
wiping dog poo off their shoe like this
morning
on an instagram story or like someone's
annoyed tweet
when they couldn't sleep at 2 a.m that
is what we're feeding ourselves
i think it's that's definitely leading
us towards more of a black
a black ball yeah yeah it's it's
it's really it's very tricky it's very
troubling
um and
i just hope that people can
be as kind to each other as possible
because it's there is definitely
a a culture of meanness that i see
on the internet that is slightly
disturbing to me and it's not even that
people are mean because everyone is mean
i mean
we're i'm not trying to pretend that i'm
like a very good
person who's never thinks mean thoughts
about people i think mean thoughts all
the time
but the difference is that i don't feel
comfortable
being publicly mean even just that
little rant that i just gave about the
guy
writing the the uh uh story where he
confused the chronology of my work and
used it to criticize me immediately
afterwards i was like oh that's not a
good thing to
talk about publicly that's weird like
because you know
if if you are publicly mean it just like
poisons you a little bit and it has this
uh i i've experienced this i've made
little tiny mean remarks and i've seen
how it comes back to get you and then i
look at these people
who are so insanely mean like as their
whole
identity on the internet and i think
like what is that doing to that person's
consciousness
they've just created an ecosystem of
meanness that is going to make them so
miserable and and they're not interested
in appreciating anything they're not
interested in
like everything is hating people for who
they're not instead of loving them for
who they are
and uh and it's like it's just not gonna
make people happy like i
i'm not even talking about the effect on
of
the target of their meanness i'm talking
about the effect on the person who is
being mean
like they are not going to be happy if
they are that way so
i don't know i i just hope that and
yeah i think like facebook and all these
social media
companies had an interesting idea that
if people's faces were attached to
things and their real names were
attached to things
maybe they would be at the very least
embarrassed to be publicly cruel
but that doesn't seem to have worked so
i don't know what the
i don't know what the solution is other
than
i don't know huge dose of psychedelics
maybe
maybe yeah maybe yeah i mean i
i think that i think it could help i you
know well i guess we'll see if it
doesn't help it was definitely worth
trying yeah
and everyone had never had a great time
what should we expect from the next
decade of psychedelics
i think it's going to be a really
interesting decade i'm very excited i'm
so excited that i'm
you know probably leaving most of the
work that i've done for the last decade
to dedicate myself entirely to
psychedelic research
um like you know scientific research
that's my plan right now
so well positioned man when you think
about the background that you've got
yourself to the platform you have the
audience you have the ability to be
like the br the brian cox of
psychedelics
um yeah and it's it's surreal having all
these companies contact me asking me to
be on their you know advisory board or
to do this or that type of research and
it's really a dream come true because
for the last years i have self-funded
the research or there's been small
amounts of money that come from the
university that i work at
and uh or did this research at and it's
uh
and it was you know it was there wasn't
there were no resources and now there
are
tremendous resources so it's that's so
exciting because you think about
the history of psychedelic research
post-60s when there was no
funding like as much as the politics of
the war on drugs interfered with
psychedelic research another big factor
that isn't talked about as much is lack
of funding
you know there were there were uh there
were people
doing psychedelic research i think up
until the
until the at the very least late 70s
and uh and
they just didn't have money they weren't
shut down by the government they didn't
have money to do it
so now that all these resources are
available i think that
some really really interesting things
might come out of the sphere
that could really help people and that's
that's very exciting in 10 years from
now
yeah i mean i hope that there is growth
in every direction i hope that there's
growth in the basic scientific
understanding of the pharmacological
mechanism of psychedelics i hope there's
growth
in the pharmaceutical implementation of
psychedelic medicines that are made
available to people that
don't want to buy them via an
unregulated black or gray market
and i also hope that there is a
decriminalization that allows people to
cultivate
psychoactive plants and fungi on their
own
create their own rituals their own
communities to do it in the way that
best suits them like i hope that there's
just an expansion of knowledge and
freedom
and i think that yeah i think it could
be great i hope i'm i am i'm not a
usually very optimistic person but it
does force me to feel a tiny bit
optimistic
that's good enough for me man yes
honestly that's good enough for me
look hamilton it's been awesome today if
people want to watch the show
uh in the uk or in the us where should
they go
it's a hard show to watch you can uh in
the uk you
might be able to get it on amazon itunes
um you can watch it hulu live you can
watch it on hulu at some point although
i don't know
when people have been ripping it and
putting it on youtube which i'm actually
really happy about except for they seem
to cut off the end of episodes of him
has it got like spanish spanish
overdubbed music has it got like
spanish hamilton or something on it they
they put in actually like soccer games
into it so that kind of stuff i don't
really like very much
but but it's you know i search for it
you'll find it it's out there it's not
that easy to find but it's available i
watch it on or would watch it on uh
amazon and then i also have a a podcast
which you can
check out at patreon.com hamilton morris
it's
largely chemistry oriented but it has uh
some other stuff that people might find
interesting
uh and it's very psychoactive
drug-oriented as you might imagine
um and uh and then this pamphlet
if anyone wants to buy this this book
which has a you know it's a great
historical document about buffalo
various it also
contains a new uh forward and
synthesis section that is really you
know useful for anyone that's interested
in the chemistry of five muodmt
uh you can get that at www dot
psychedelic toad of the sonoran desert
dot com
so are there any of those left i know
you had to do a bunch of different runs
right
yeah the first one sold out in an hour
that was pretty wild then the second one
sold out
in a day and then there's a third very
a larger final printing that has not
sold out so if anyone wants to pre-order
it
as of this discussion um
it's there's still a good number of them
left and 100
of the profit goes to the michael j fox
foundation for parkinson's research so
amazing i'll link that in the show notes
below if anyone wants to pick one up
along with wherever i can find
hamilton's pharmacopoeia
dude i'm really excited to see what your
work has in store for you i know it's
the final season of
your show and you're now dedicating
yourself fully to the the chemistry so
it's like
white lab coat as opposed to like sun
hat and
like white shirt and jeans for the for
the next few years but
it's going to be exciting to watch yeah
yeah thank you
i enjoyed the conversation and uh i'll
talk to you later
[Music]